on the outskirts of bamako a meat market
has churned into a makeshift camp for
those fleeing the violence in central
Mali adamu and her newborn Hawa have
just arrived from mukti she fears for
her life so we have hidden her identity
for her safety despite maintaining a
peacekeeping force nearby the U.N did
not intervene when her Village was
torched she says those involved in the
attack were not Al-Qaeda or isil
Fighters but those meant to protect her
speaking out could get her killed it's
the Malian forces and their Partners the
white skin ones who attacked us I was
terrified they set our homes and
Villages alight the U.N accuses Malian
forces and foreign Fighters believed to
be Russian mercenaries from the Wagner
group of war crimes including torture
rape and arbitrary killings at the U.N
security Council mali's foreign minister
from its military Junta denied any
wrongdoing
the U.N peacekeeping mission is the
problem by feeling ethnic and communal
tensions exacerbated by serious
allegations
Molly is calling for the immediate
departure of the U.N peacekeeping
Mission saying there is no peace to keep
there have been protests in bamako
against the decade-long U.N presence
protesters blamed the 13 000 soldiers
for the deteriorating security situation
but for those displaced the UN
peacekeeping Mission known as minusma is
not the problem
the situation is bad before we thought
armed groups were the threat but now
it's the Malian Army and its partners
that we're scared of
we really don't know who to trust but
it's not in our interests for the
peacekeepers to leave they help us
survive we can't do without them nearly
half a million Millions have been
displaced in the past decade according
to the U.N Aid agencies fear the
departure of the U.N peacekeeping
Mission would turn the humanitarian
crisis into a disaster there is no
electricity no running water every time
I come to this makeshift Camp it appears
to grow bigger in size and more crowded
with displaced people living in dire
circumstances without any help from the
government
mali's military Junta says with the help
of the Russians it is gaining ground
clearing Village after Village of armed
groups and yet people living here are
too scared to go home Nicholas Hawk Al
Jazeera Barako